this side street hides a very unusual
old people's home built especially for
survivors of the Holocaust who live
below the poverty line 87 year old
former nurse you would at pause and swag
is one of them from the age of nine she
endured life in the ghetto before
surviving three concentration camps she
lives in a basement flat packed with
memories from her life they cover
universe FTW I have company here and
I've made friends I don't have to do
things alone anymore and that means a
lot to me I'm not the youngest anymore
but the past lives on in me the Ferger
me married lived a girl toy company
Ferguson sketches from her time and
today's Ian strut concentration camp
hang on the walls born in Czechoslovakia
you'd it was 14 when she was deported
from today's inched up to Auschwitz and
finally to bergen-belsen pictures taken
before the war show a happy family life
they're all memories she strives to keep
alive this is the rift eek it's very
important our memories are not forgotten
Divya have my generation is really the
last of all those who survived Auschwitz
debates you know family zeen did or how
its gig onions in there saw us to be
found in neighbors who have suffered a
similar fate yudit doesn't have to go
far to find company when she feels
lonely next door in the canteen
volunteers are preparing lunch she
Montebourg founder of the helping hands
initiative knows the problem survivors
have well Jonas humor a law these people
are often in a difficult mental or
financial situation they need this place
the traumas experienced in the camps
come back more often the older they get
it gets amplified especially if they
were learn them without help and their
bodies slowly start to fail though bill
discussion the canteen as the central
meeting place for those who live here
judit comes every day there's a waiting
list for the home and a soup kitchen for
those who aren't able to live here
it's about building a community onion
yuck nasty I didn't know that such a
place existed I've been here for a year
and I'm really happy little it sir is
it's numb dish we gather at the table
and eat together or don't eat together
the home can also be a place of
lightheartedness you'd its generation
experienced little of that feeling but
their main wish is that they and their
stories are never forgotten